the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so for today we're just going to break
you guys up into groups so kenneth and
andrea you guys could work together
today for the rest of class Paul Yulia
and David and since we have an odd
number there's going to be a group of
three then Nathan and Joshua you guys
can film each other and I know that
you're going to be a little bit limited
with locations today so if you wanted to
film on location you might not be able
to do that for today but just get
comfortable with like the movements of
the camera incorporating the stuff Chris
talked about earlier that's what we want
you guys to do today and bike go team
funny
Sally
in a year 2009 famous astrophysicist
Stephen Hawking can actually go solo
artist
ok
but also charging you rent not contain
the travelin this [ __ ] through all sorts
of wine orders even litza absolutely no
one came
just going for me that was home I mean
this could be a different way yeah half
a second of a shock response on the
couch or where they are och sorry we are
you should get my snacks and water grab
one and one and so like I'm kind of like
okay effectiveness